au procès des assassins présumés du
préfet irignac plusieurs accusés se sont
rétractées et ont tenté jeudi
d'innocenter le tueur présumé Yvan
Colonna des déclarations qui ont conduit
la veuve du préfet madame Dominique
herignac A s'exprimer pour la première
fois depuis le début du procès sur place
Dominique verdaillan et Mathieu birden
les accusés eux-mêmes rendent à la
dignité de Dominic Erignac chaque jour
le face à face est tendu mais
respectueux ce matin 4 des accusés ont
mis hors de causes Ivan Colonna pour eux
il n'est pas l'assassin du préfet
j'ai du mal à les croire comment est-ce
qu'on peut
avouer d'une manière si précise et puis
tenait tout se rétracter
je ne comprends pas il serait tracte de
devant des
un acte collectif
tout ça me paraît bien facile ce sont
des hommes qui ont sont pas des enfants
ce sont des hommes qui ont 40 ans et qui
ont décidé de faire quelque chose
oui
les Corses revendiquent beaucoup
être des hommes d'honneur et je pense
que là
je trouve qu'il le manque d'honneur et
de panache on ne tue pas quelqu'un parce
qu'il est préfet et qu'il représente
quelque chose la vie est quelque chose
de plus important de on ne peut pas
faire ça je les ai beaucoup regardé dans
les yeux
d'ailleurs ils ont baissé les yeux
mais maintenant je
n'ai pas envie de les regarder
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
leur dire non
eux ils t'ont qu'à se défendre ils ont
qu'à dire ce qu'ils ont à dire
non moi je n'ai pas envie de parler
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de la suite
ce procès va encore durer trois semaines
oui
en ce moment je ne j'avoue que je suis
un peu désespéré
j'aimerais bien que le procès avance
et que l'on trouve peut-être une réponse